STEVE: 8:37 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
WE’RE BACK WITH A FOX NEWS ALERT
THE USA HAS SHATTERED ITS DAILY
RECORD IN COVID CASES OVERNIGHT,
BRIAN.
BRIAN:  MORE THAN 77,000 NEW
CASES REPORTED, THAT’S 10,000
MORE CASES THAN THE PREVIOUS
RECORD.
>> KATIE: 969 DEATHS WERE
REPORTED THE LARGEST SPIKE IN
OVER A MONTH.
LET’S BRING IN KELLYANNE CONWAY,
THE COUNSELOR NOT PRESIDENT FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE NOW GOOD MORNING
>> GOOD MORNING, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
>> KATIE: LET’S START FIRST
WITH YOUR REACTION TO THESE NEW
CORONAVIRUS CASES OVERNIGHT AND
THE NUMBERS.
>> WELL THIS IS EXACTLY WHY,
KATIE, AND BRIAN AND STEVE, THAT
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE THE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
TALKING ABOUT THIS DUAL MEDICAL
AND FINANCIAL CRISIS THAT THE
COUNTRY IS FACING THAT THIS
PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
NAVIGATING FOR MANY MONTHS NOW.
I AM TOLD IN THE CORONAVIRUS
TASK FORCE I SIT RIGHT BEHIND
DR.  BIRX AND DR. FAUCI, MOST
DAYS WHEN I CAN BE IN THERE THAT
WE ARE CONTINUING TO SURGE
SUPPLIES, ICU CAPACITY,
VENTILATORS, EVERYBODY HAS
NEEDED A VENTILATOR HAS GOTTEN A
VENTILATOR.
WE CONTINUE TO PROVIDE TESTING
AND THE MATERIALS THESE GOVERNOR
S NEED IN THESE HOTSPOT
SURGES.
WE DID SEE AN INCREASE IN ABOUT
JUNE 10 TO JUNE 16 AND MAYBE A
LAGGING INDICATOR FROM SOME OF
THE MEMORIAL DAY ACTIVITIES WHEN
A LOT OF AMERICANS JUST SAID
LOOK I’VE BEEN IN LOCKDOWN FOR
MANY MONTHS, FIRST OFFICIAL
WEEKEND OF SUMMER I’M GOING TO
GET OUT THERE BUT I THINK THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT
PEOPLE CAN DO IS OUR TESTS AND
THE ASSISTANT SECRETARY OF
HEALTH FOR THE WHOLE NATION SAID
AT RECENTLY AS YESTERDAY WHICH
IS CLOSE THE INDOOR BARS, AND
WEAR A MASK.
GET OUR SCHOOLS REOPENED AS WELL
DON’T LET THESE KIDS
SUFFER BECAUSE EVERYTHING IS
SPEAKING UP.
ALSO, WE HAD GREAT NEWS THIS
WEEK.
AS THIS PRESIDENT HAS LED THE
EFFORT TO THE MOST RAPID AND
DEEPEST MONETARY INVESTMENT IN
VACCINES AND THERAPEUTICS, ON
THIS ISSUE, REALLY IN OUR
NATIONS HISTORY, DR. FAUCI
EARLIER THIS WEEK SAID THIS IS
GREAT NEWS THAT WE HAD AN
INITIAL TEST OF 45 VOLUNTEERS
WHO HAD CORONAVIRUS AND THEY
BUILT UP THOSE ANTIBODIES IN
THEIR BLOODSTREAM.
ON JULY 27 NEXT WEEK, WE’LL GO,
WE’RE GOING TO HAVE THE TEST OF
30,000 INDIVIDUALS AND HOPEFULLY
THIS L BE ANOTHER MAJOR LEAP
FORWARD TO GETTING THE TYPE OF
VACCINES THAT WE ALL KNOW WILL
HELP TO MITIGATE THIS DAMAGE.
STEVE: ABSOLUTELY, ALL OF OUR
FINGERS ARE CROSSED THAT IT
COMES SOONER THAN LATER BUT AND
KELLYANNE WITHOUT A DOUBT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING A
LOT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
COMPLETELY MOBILIZED AND YET HOW
DO YOU EXPLAIN WHY THE PRESIDENT
’S NUMBERS ON POLL
ING WITH APPROVAL AND
DISAPPROVAL ARE UNDER WATER WHEN
IT COMES TO COVID?
YOU LOOK AT THE DATA, FROM
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE POLLING, AND
JOE BIDEN ACTUALLY BEATS THE
PRESIDENT ON COVID RESPONSE
AND JOE BIDEN IS IN THE BASEMENT
NOT DOING ANYTHING.
>> WELL THAT HAS BENEFITED JOE
BIDEN.
THE LESS JOE BIDEN IS BETTER FOR
JOE BIDEN I WOULD NOTE THAT
IN OTHER POLLING, JOE BIDEN’S
NEGATIVES HAVE INCREASED BECAUSE
WE’VE SEEN A LITTLE BIT MORE OF
HIM.
I THOUGHT HE WAS RUNNING FOR
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES BUT APPARENTLY HE’S
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR OF
PENNSYLVANIA BECAUSE IT’S ONE
EXCEPTION, HE’S NOT LEFT
DELAWARE OR  PENNSYLVANIA IN
MANY MANY MONTHS, AND THAT IS
NOT THE WAY SOMEBODY SHOULD BE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT OF ALL 50
STATES.
HE SHOULD GO OUT THERE, MEET
PEOPLE, ENGAGE WITH THEM, BUT IT
DOES BENEFIT HIM.
NOW, I’M GOING TO ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT WHY THE PRESIDENT
’S NUMBERS MAYBE A
LITTLE SOFTER ON THE HANDLING OF
CORONAVIRUS.
MY OWN VIEW, WHICH IS DIFFERENT
THAN SOME PEOPLE HERE, IS THREE
THINGS.
ONE, THE PRESIDENT’S NUMBERS
WERE MUCH HIGHER WHEN HE WAS OUT
THERE BRIEFING EVERYBODY ON HIS
DAY BY DAY BASIS ABOUT THE
CORONAVIRUS.
JUST GIVING PEOPLE THE
INFORMATION.
THEY WERE OUT THERE EVERY DAY
WHEN WE HAD AT SOME POINT 2,500
DEATHS IN ONE DAY, AT THE
HIGHEST LEVEL AND I GUESS IT WAS
APRIL OR  SO, MARCH AND APRIL,
AND THE PRESIDENT AND THE TASK
FORCE WERE THERE MOST DAYS,
GIVING THE INFORMATION.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE
DOING THAT.
I’VE GOT SOME COLLEAGUES BEHIND
ME.
STEVE: WHY DID HE STOP?
>> SOME PEOPLE ARE ENCOURAGING
HIM TO STOP.
HE’S GOT A TASK FORCE AND
DOCTORS AND ECONOMISTS AND OF
COURSE THE VICE PRESIDENT
LEADING THE TASK FORCE BUT
PEOPLE WANT INFORMATION AND THIS
COUNTRY, FOLLOWED
INSTRUCTIONS.
THEY STAYED INSIDE AND SOCIALLY
DISTANCED AND BECAME THE TEACHER
S HELPING THEIR KIDS.
STEVE: KELLYANNE I THINK YOU’RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
I THINK THAT THAT WOULD MAKE IT
LOOK, APPEAR, THAT THE PRESIDENT
WAS FULLY ENGAGED ON IT BECAUSE
EVERY NIGHT AT 5:00 IN THE 5:00
HOUR HE WOULD COME OUT AND HE
WOULD BRIEF THE NATION ON THE
VERY LATEST.
>> IT’S WILD RATINGS.
PEOPLE WERE TUNING IN AND IT
DOESN’T VEHICLE TO BE TWO HOURS
BUT IT SHOULD BE, SHOULDN’T BE
ZERO MINUTES EITHER.
STEVE: IT’S A GOOD IDEA.
>> THE PRESIDENT WAS AT THE
PODIUM SAYING I WANT TO GIVE YOU
THE FACTS AND THE FIGURES AS TO
WHAT WE’VE BEEN ABLE TO DO.
MILLIONS OF PIECES OF PPE AND
VENTILATORS AND VACCINE
DEVELOPMENT AND THE LIKE BUT
ALSO I WANT TO SAY THAT THIS
PRESIDENT SPEAKS REGULARLY
TO THE GOVERNORS WHO ARE CALLING
HIM ABOUT THESE HOTSPOTS ABOUT
THESE SURGES, WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THEM, BUT THAT’S
NOT EVERYWHERE AND WE HAVE TO
MAKE VERY CLEAR, AND I THINK THE
OTHER REASON THE PRESIDENT’S
NUMBERS ARE NEGATIVE IS BECAUSE
HE CAN NEVER GET A FAIR SHAKE
BUT LOOK THE POLL HAS 24%
REPUBLICANS.
THE WALL STREET JOURNAL POLL 26%
REPUBLICAN.
THE ABC NEWS WASHINGTON POLL 24%
REPUBLICAN SO THAT IS RIDICULOUS
TO THINK THAT LIKELY VOTERS ARE
ONLY 24% REPUBLICAN SO IF YOU
HAVE A 10% DIFFERENCE, PLUS 10
DEMOCRAT IN YOUR SAMPLE, AND
YOU’RE ASKING BALLOT TESTS OR
APPROVAL RATINGS BETWEEN BIDEN
AND TRUMP YOU’RE GOING TO GET A
VERY SKEWED RESULT SO I WOULD
CAUTION, I WOULD URGE MANY OF
ALL OF THESE OUTLETS THAT HAVE
THE POLLING ALL WRONG IN 2016,
TO SHARPEN UP, TO LOOK AT YOUR
SCIENCE AND YOUR ART BECAUSE
NONE OF THEM GOT FIRED BY THE
WAY.
THEY ALSO HAVE THEIR JOBS, IT’S
NOT REALLY AMERITOCRACY, AND THE
C-SUITE WOULD HAVE BEEN
CLEANED OUT AND THE SHAREHOLDERS
WOULD HAVE REVOLTED AND THE
CONSUMERS WOULD LOOK
ELSEWHERE FOR PRODUCTS AND
SERVICES BUT THAT’S FINE THEY
ARE ALL STILL THERE BUT THEIR
POLLING IS STILL A HOT MESS.
I WOULD NOTE THOUGH THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS AT 54% IN SOME
OF THE POLLS THAT ONLY HAVE 24%
REPUBLICAN SAMPLING AND 54% IS
HANDLING THE ECONOMY AND I THINK
IF HE GETS OUT THERE AND TALKS
ABOUT THE MEDICAL AND FINANCIAL
CRISIS THEN I THINK IT’LL BE
MUCH BETTER AND HE’S GOT DR.
FAUCI THERE, HE’S GOT DR.
BIRX, DR. REDFIELD, OUR
DOCTORS ARE OUT THERE,
ECONOMISTS BUT ALSO LOOK AT
WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH THE
ECONOMY THIS PRESIDENT IS
BULLISHLY LEADING FOR THE
COUNTRY.
WE JUST HAVE SO MUCH MORE JOB
PRODUCTION.
YESTERDAY THE DEREG EVENT WAS
INCREDIBLE BECAUSE THIS
PRESIDENT SAID FOR YEARS
HIS TAX CUT AND JOB ACT CREATED
A GREAT DEAL OF WEALTH FOR
MIDDLE CLASS AMERICANS GOT
THAT BUSINESS TAX RATE FROM 35%
DOWN TO 21% BUT THE PRESIDENT
SAID HE THINKS HIS DEREG AGENDA
IS JUST AS IMPORTANT AND FOR
SOME BUSINESS OWNERS,
PROPERTY OWNER, PUBLIC SCHOOL
PARENTS, SMALL BUSINESSES, IT’S
EVEN MORE IMPORTANT.
WE SAID IN THE CAMPAIGN LAST
TIME, TWO REGULATIONS OUT FOR
EVERY NEW ONE IN, IT’S 8:1
NOW, AND IT’S BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN SAVINGS.
BRIAN:  KELLYANNE I THINK YOU
KNOW THIS THOUGH EVERYTHING
PALES IN COMPARISON TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE PANDEMIC.
DOES IT EFFECT EVERYBODY’S LIFE,
BUSINESS OWNERS, FAMILIES,
SPORTS WHATEVER.
I DON’T NEED TO TELL YOU THAT.
I WATCHED TED ROLLINS YESTERDAY
ON LOU DOBBS, BECAUSE SOMETIMES
I WATCH FOX BUSINESS AND HE
KNOWS THERE’S BEEN A CHANGE WITH
BRAD PRASCALE AND ONE OF THE
THINGS WAS YOU GOT TO BRING
KELLYANNE BACK.
WILL YOU EVER GO BACK AND
REPRODUCE WHAT YOU DID IN 2016
STEVE: SHE MADE HISTORY.
>> WELL THANK YOU FOR THAT,
KELLYANNE NEVER WENT AWAY
ACTUALLY, HERE I AM AND I AM AT
THE WHITE HOUSE WHERE THE
PRESIDENT WANTS ME TO BE AND
HE AND I HAVE HAD THIS
CONVERSATION MANY TIMES.
I WANT TO BE WHERE MY BEST AND
HIGHEST USE IS FOR THE PRESIDENT
, AND I STILL
BELIEVE THAT A PRESIDENT RUNNING
FOR RE-ELECTION, THOSE FORTUNES
RISE AND FALL MOSTLY ON WHAT IS
DONE WHERE HE IS, IN THIS
BUILDING, BUT HE KNOWS HOW
INVOLVED I AM.
I’VE BEEN BY HIS SIDE FOR FOUR
STRAIGHT YEARS TRYING TO PUSH,
TRYING TO BE A VERY SMALL PERSON
PUSHING UP THE BOULDER UP THE
HILL OF THE TRUMP
ADMINITRATION AGENDA AND I DID
SEE EARLIER, AND I THANK YOU FOR
THAT I SAW YOUR SEGMENT
STEVE WITH COREY LEWANDOWSKI AND
OTHER CAMPAIGN MANAGERS AND
CLOSE CON ANY DON’T OF THE
PRESIDENT STILL AND
CONTINUING AND WHEN YOU SAID IT
WAS THE FIRST WOMAN TO BE
CAMPAIGN MANAGER SUCCESSFULLY I
WAS ALSO THE ONLY WOMAN IN THE
DEBATE PREP MOST OF THE TIME
, AND I WOULD EXPECT
THAT EVEN IF I HAVE TO TAKE
VACATION TIME I WILL BE THERE AS
WELL BECAUSE THAT’S GOING TO
BE MUST SEE TV BUT I THINK THAT
I’M THE PERSON, THE LONGEST-
SERVING FEMALE HERE
WHO WORKS IN THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN POLICY AND COMMUNICATION
AND DONALD TRUMP AS PRESIDENT
HAS HAD AN IMPACT ON REAL PEOPLE
’S LIVES.
YOU’RE GOING TO SEE THAT AT OUR
CONVENTION AND HEAR THAT IN
THESE DEBATES.
JOE BIDEN SIMPLY CAN’T COMPETE
IN HIS 47 YEARS AS A LOCKNESS
MONSTER IN THE D.C.
SWAMP WITH FOUR YEARS OF THE
TRUMP RECORD HE JUST HAS
IMPACTS ON PEOPLE’S LIVES AND
WE’LL HAVE THE PEOPLE THERE TO
TALK ABOUT IT AND THIS PRESIDENT
WHOSE A MASTERFUL, FEARLESS
DEBATE OR  , YOU SAW HIS TAKE ON
HILLARY CLINTON AND THE ACCESS
HOLLYWOOD TAPE TWO DAYS LATER
AND HE CLEANED HER CLOCK, SHE
NEVER TOOK HIM SERIOUSLY AND
THEN IN THAT FINAL DEBATE
OCTOBER 19, 2016, PRESIDENT
TRUMP DID SOMETHING THAT NO
REPUBLICAN OR  PRO-LIFE
CONSERVATIVE CANDIDATE I’D
WORKED WITH FOR DECK DECADES HAD
EVER DONE WHICH IS THIS
MANHATTAN MALE BILLIONAIRE,
FOR MOST OF HIS ADULT LIFE HAD
BEEN PRO CHOICE, HE SAID YOU
WOULD RIP THAT BABY OUT OF ITS
MOTHERS WOMB WITH AN HOUR TO GO
AND IT REALLY MADE SUCH A
DIFFERENCE.
THAT’S HIS SELECTION OF VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE, AND THOSE WERE
JUST PROMISES.
NOW HE’S DELIVERED ON THAT
AGENDA.
I READ HERE THE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO REDUCE THEIR CONVENTION
TO 300 PEOPLE.
THAT IS A SMALL SECOND WEDDING
WHERE I COME FROM FOLKS.
THAT IS NOT A POLITICAL
CONVENTION.
STEVE: [LAUGHTER]
THAT’S FUNNY.
>> SO HERE I AM.
I NEVER WENT AWAY.
BRIAN:  GOTCHA.
>> KATIE: AND DIDN’T
NECESSARILY GET THE CREDIT.
>> AND I THINK, YOU KNOW WHAT?
I GET IT WHERE IT MATTERS I HAVE
A GREAT CONNECTION TO DEBATES
AND THE GRASSROOTS I HAVE MY
ONLY PERSONAL DEBATE WITH THE
PRESIDENT, LOTS OF PEOPLE
TRYING TO THROW LOGS ON MY WAY,
REFLECTS POORLY ON THEM NOT ON
ME AND WHAT I WANT TO SAY TO YOU
IS BRAD PARSCALE DID A GREAT JOB
WITH DIGITAL, I’M GLAD HE WILL
STAY ON AND DO THAT AND UNDER
BRAD’S STEWARDSHIP, THEY HAVE A
HUGE DIGITAL INFRASTRUCTURE,
2 MILLION OR  SO VOLUNTEERS, A
BIG CAMPAIGN STAFF LOOK 2016 WE
WERE UNDER STAFFED, UNDER
RESOURCED BUT WE WERE ALSO
UNDERESTIMATING THE UNDERDOGS.
I THINK THIS TIME THE PRESIDENT
IS ALSO UNDERESTIMATING THE
UNDERDOGS AND I’D LIKE TO
SEE THE 2020 CAMPAIGN HAVE THE
SAME SWAGGER AND HUNGER AND
THE JOB THAT WE HAD IN 2016 SO I
THINK THAT WILL HAVE TRUMP ON IT
AND LAST THING I’LL SAY TO YOU
--
STEVE: QUICKLY.
>> LAST THING I’LL SAY IS I SEE
A LOT OF THE SAME TRENDS OF
2016.
SOME THINGS ARE DIFFERENT BUT I
SEE JOE BIDEN AS SORT OF HILLARY
IN THAT WAY TOO HE’S GOING TO
TRY TO RUN ON EXPERIENCE AND
HAVE ALL OF THE KINGS HORSES AND
ALL THE KINGS MEN AND PRESIDENT
TRUMP IN BEING UNDERESTIMATED
THIS TIME WILL BE ABLE TO SAY
HERE IS THE RESULTS I HAVE
DELIVERED AND PEOPLE WELL HEAR
FOR THE FIRST TIME SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT WE TALK ABOUT
EVERY DAY.
PEOPLE WHO DON’T PAY ATTENTION
TO POLITICS AND NEVER WATCH A
RALLY WILL ABSOLUTELY TUNE INTO
THE CONVENTION TO THE DEBATE TO
LEARN TO SEE THE CONTRAST.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT, LET’S SEE IF
THEY DO RESEARCH THE PRESIDENT’S
DAILY CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE
MEETING.